okay we've got a voicemail to play for  you our voicemail number is two one nine  to david p let's take a listen to this  voicemail that came in hey David you  know it's similar to saying we're not in  to submit ik we have a Jewish lawyer  would be I don't dislike Jews i watch  the david packard show and i'd i just  think that would be even funnier to hear  coming out of someone's mouth if anyone  in the audience is ever told that line  right i have no problem with jews  whatsoever i regularly watch the david  pakman show please email in and tell me  about that because i absolutely want to  hear about that on today's bonus show i  will talk about my vacation Pat will  talk about his vacation and we will get  caught up for starting 2018 david  pakman.com slash membership and  patreon.com slash david pakman show are  the two ways to get instant access to  the world-famous bonus show